come on now
okay oh the usher hello galinari you
heard about that check what's your books
uh usher yeah tell us what tell us
come on man i i don't believe that i got
faith in uh he was not throwing our
fake hundred dollar bill with his face
on it no i don't believe that that's
that's
not i could not believe that no i don't
believe that hey sure oh so you gotta
defend yourself i do not believe you
again
you got it bad uh sir if you did i
shouldn't do that i shouldn't do that no
that call right truck usher bucks
that's your bucks oh you don't pay no
bills us your bucks
i know no you know i don't know uh i'm
just i i
that's what you heard what what's the
story cause i i kind of heard this very
shack but i didn't
my ear wasn't to the street all the way
no he was at a uh
store a grocery shop they had a lot of
groceries in there
chickens and wings and chickens he was
at a grocery store and a song came on
and he started making it rain
okay and then one of
[Laughter]
it's a grocery store you get legs thighs
wings
that's where you go together it's a
grocery store